my name is Ian Heskett this is my wife
Jennifer we live here in Kalamazoo
Michigan got two kids couple pets and
and that's it that's us
when I met you I worked in hair salon
and I was up doing hair one night with
his sister and another co-worker of ours
said why don't you introduce Jen to Ian
and his sister said I don't know he's
really strange and I was like okay let's
go Alex trained so I'm assuming you're
here to do a debt free scream yes we are
cool I didn't have a credit card up
until I was early 20s the Marine Corps
ball was coming up and I was broke I
need to have money for life you know
we're gonna be going out or gonna be
having a good time so I got a credit
card through the local credit union that
it was like $2,000 credit limit or
something like that I was like sweet
like I'm good what happened in your mind
Jennifer this said okay I'm gonna do
this well we had some debt that was
really heavy on our relationship the
body-mind had started um started a
business we funded most of the startup
with credit cards between him I so by
the time it comes time for us to clean
up our personal debt I had these
personal credit cards I have a lot of
business expenses on them and she was
somewhat aware of you know the
operations and everything but she did
was not aware of the amount of credit
card debt that we
accumulated the first time you shut down
to do a budget how'd it work um I might
have cried you know we sat down on the
couch we had the computer and the budget
pulled up and all the receipts that we
had saved and we were actually going
through and looking seeing like where
our money's going when we filled out I
was like seventy some thousand dollars
we're like we don't even make that much
for me that was like when I needed to do
something about it
it was more like emotional for me
learning that we had this much debt
because I was I was pregnant and I was
really hoping to be able to stay home
but it was just really a turning point
emotionally for me my sister my brother
went through the FPU class at our old
church and we wanted to do it but she
was pregnant and there was going to
carry on - you know through the through
the birth so we were kind of like we'll
just wing it more or less rapport kind
of do it our way I came home from work I
came home from somewhere and this book
in these CDs were sitting on the kitchen
camera I was like what's this and she's
like you know between the two of us like
I'm definitely the nerd and she's
definitely free spirit so like within
the first couple pages of you know dave
has learned this and this and she's like
oh like I'm gonna trying to come out
yeah
bombarded with information she's like
like I'm really excited for you honey
but we need to talk
I came to him and told him I was ready
to sell my car I mean that was probably
for him when he knew I was all-in we
were making so many cuts and so many
sacrifices and it started turning into a
little bit of like a challenge like how
much can I save us on groceries those
little victories are seriously like we
totally celebrated yes we sold what else
do we sell I'm sorry bunch of furniture
and we had a 19 what year was my right
92 1992 Jeep Wrangler Ian drove Michigan
winters down here with no heat in this
Wrangler because we were not gonna spend
money on a vehicle at this point and
then we would dream about I was like
someday we're gonna have cheese like I
know that she's coming back baby we're
gonna have beer and it's gonna be good
yeah it is not gonna be a one dollar
beer that what that was it I was like I
just kind of sat back and we're like
dude we just paid off the last debt
student loans gone credit cards are all
gone we got two vehicles that are paid
for him albeit one was a rusty old
drafty OG but I think was awesome man 3
2 1
what
once we were debt-free I was like hey no
shopping like that's going to eat let's
go do dinner he's like no there are more
steps like we still have steps to go
like we have our retirement to fund we
have our children's college fund you've
got our three to six months of emergency
funds we took a real long you know three
week long vacation that we were able to
pay for with cash we saved up all year
and we're paying we're paying extra on
the mortgage every every month now and
our girls are set up for a different
life it's cool to know that like they're
gonna learn about money growing up and
they're not gonna have to be in any sort
of position that we were enter that you
know millions of people are in over they
just tied down by debt
not knowing what to do that's really the
most exciting thing for me
we paid off seventy four thousand
dollars
and twelve months time with a lot of
hard work a lot of dedication
it's something we kind of down without
communication we are now debt-free
you
you